Hey, Simon says, how can we measure market saturation for digital assets?
That's that I might need you to give a little bit more information on that.
Maybe you can and I can answer it on a on a comment.
But guys, I'm telling you, those of you guys that are worried about saturation,
we are there.
Go watch my videos, type in saturation.
Is ranking saturated on YouTube?
And go listen to my logical answers.
OK, this is not saturated.
And just because you guys are seeing other rank and rep people, other marketers,
does not mean it's saturated.
Just because there's someone else, the website doesn't mean you can't have one.
Just because there's somebody else that, you know, sorry,
just because there is somebody that has a website in your niche and city
does not mean they even have a client.
It doesn't even mean that they're even in the business anymore.
It doesn't mean that they know how to sell and create a deal.
You guys have to remember that those websites that you guys see
and get so scared of there are just like another local business.
OK, don't worry about that. Keep going.